[Music]
foreign
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month today we're heading back a couple
of decades to the year 2001. it was the
year that marked the launch of iTunes
and Wikipedia and it was a pretty great
year for TV and movies too which
thankfully were there to become a very
welcome distraction after our lives
changed forever shows like Survivor The
West Wing and Sex and the City were all
the rage around the water cooler and we
were introduced to eventual film
franchises revolving around a green
animated ogre a young wizard named Harry
a Lord of the Rings and a group of
people who like to do things Fast and
Furious so gather round cause it's time
for your 2001 year in review
thank you
bronzo I've gone above you I've spoken
to your section chief someday you'll
thank me or you won't I don't care
you'll be alive
inspector potsy
is this Clarisse
well hello glories
February of 2001 served up the film
Hannibal the highly anticipated sequel
to 1991's monster hit Silence of the
Lambs this time Julianne Moore steps
into the role of Clarice Starling who
seven years after the events of the
first film is still attempting to
apprehend cannibalistic serial killer
Hannibal Lecter played once again by
Anthony Hopkins Hannibal was directed by
Ridley Scott and based on the 1999 novel
by Thomas Harris who also wrote the
first book and spent several years
writing this after the success of the
first film you look wow ridiculous
if you touch me
understood do right you live through
this spoken like a true Protestant
better hurry things might go faster if
you hand me the night despite mixed
reviews the film did very well at the
box office to the tune of over 351
million dollars but it was ultimately
deemed inferior to its predecessor
critics say while superbly acted and
stylishly filmed Hannibal lacks the
character interaction between the two
leads which made the first film so
engrossing
[Music]
[Applause]
no that's because it opens up into
one doesn't it opens up into a sphere
opening in May was The Mummy Returns a
sequel to the 1999 film The Mummy this
one picks up 10 years after the events
of the first film with Brendan Fraser's
Rick O'Connell settled in 1935 London
married to Evelyn played by Rachel Weiss
and raising their son but they soon find
themselves in a race to save the world
from unspeakable evil and rescue their
son before it's too late The Mummy
Returns marks the big screen acting
debut for Dwayne Johnson whose only
spoken lines in the film are in ancient
Egyptian but he would get his turn with
the 2002 prequel The Scorpion King set 5
000 years prior and with Johnson in the
starring role
foreign
the film's 70 million dollar opening
weekend total made it the second highest
opening ever at the time behind the Lost
World Jurassic Park on its way to
grossing over 435 million dollars
worldwide critics say and The Mummy
Returns the special effects are
impressive but the character seems
secondary to the computer-generated
imagery evening
mirror mirror on the wall is this not
the most perfect Kingdom of them all
well technically you're not a king uh
Thelonious
you were saying what I mean is that
you're not a king yet also coming in May
was the animated film Shrek starring
Mike Myers in the titular role and
Loosely based on William stieg's 1990
picture book of the same name in the
film Shrek's peaceful life of solitude
is disrupted by an invasion of banished
fairy tale characters in order to get
his life back Shrek sets out to find and
rescue Princess Fiona voiced by Cameron
Diaz who has an ogre related secret of
her own Nicholas Cage was offered the
role of Shrek but turned it down in part
because he didn't want to look like an
ogre so Chris Farley was cast and
recorded much of the dialogue but he
died in 1997 before his work was
completed so Mike Myers took over the
role and eventually changed the accent
example okay
um
ogres are like onions
they stay yes no oh they make you cry no
oh you leave them out in the sun they
get all brown start sprouting little
white hairs no layers Shrek was chosen
to compete for the Palm Dior at the 2001
canned Film Festival becoming the first
animated film to do so since 1953's
Peter Pan before picking up an Oscar for
best animated feature critics say while
simultaneously embracing and subverting
fairy tales the irreverent Shrek also
manages to tweak Disney's nose provide a
moral message to children and offer
viewers a funny fast-paced ride
show will be a magnificent opulent
tremendous stupendous gargantuan
bedazzled the sensual ravishment it will
be
singing and dancing its way in the
theaters in May was baz luhrmann's film
Moulin Rouge this one takes place in a
gaudy and glamorous Nightclub at the
cusp of the 20th century where a young
poet played by Ewan McGregor starts a
passionate affair with the club's most
notorious and beautiful star played by
Nicole Kidman Moulin Rouge could have
looked a bit different considering
Leonardo DiCaprio Heath Ledger and Jake
Gyllenhaal reportedly all auditioned for
the role of Christian before Ewan
McGregor was cast
thank you for curing me my ridiculous
obsession with love
[Music]
and speaking of big stars it was a bit
of a rough shoot for Nicole Kidman who
broke her ribs twice once when she was
lifted into the air during a number and
again when a corset was pulled too tight
hopefully the Best Actor's Oscar
nomination she got one of eight knobs
for the movie made her feel a little bit
better critics say a love it or hated
experience Moulin Rouge is all style all
giddy over-the-top spectacle but it's
also daring in its vision and wildly
original
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
speeding into a June release in 2001 was
the Fast and the Furious directed by Rob
Cohen who would go on to direct triple X
the following year Paul Walker plays
LAPD officer Brian O'Connor who goes
undercover in the world of street racing
and has taken under the wing of Vin
Diesel's Dominic Toretto and Brian
ultimately has to decide where his
loyalties lie
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you smiling about dude almost
had you
[Applause]
you almost have me you never had me you
never had your car
the film would go on to launch a
franchise that includes at least 10
films along with tie-in products like
video games Amusement Park attractions
toys and clothing but the Fast and the
Furious could have been something else
altogether considering its original
title was Redline and Eminem was
reportedly offered the role of Brian
O'Connor but he turned it down to work
on Eight Mile so Paul Walker got the
part on the strength of his performance
in the skulls the year before and he
will reprise his role in a bunch of
those sequels up until and even after
his death in 2013. critics say sleek and
shiny on the surface The Fast and the
Furious recalls those cheesy teenage
exploitation flicks of the 1950s
foreign
woods and this is freezer woods and
we're both Gemini vegetarians I have a
bachelor's degree in fashion
merchandising from Cula and I was a Zeta
Lambda new sweetheart president of my
sorority Delta new and last year I was
homecoming queen
theaters in July of 2001 on its way to
becoming a sleeper hit was Legally
Blonde based on Amanda Brown's 2001
novel of the same name Reese Witherspoon
stars as fashion student and Sorority
Girl L Woods who is on the fast track to
a perfect life until her boyfriend
breaks up with her before he heads off
to Harvard Law School Elle Wills her way
into the same school in an effort to win
him back but things don't go quite as
plans Witherspoon may have missed out on
winning an MTV movie award for her role
no thanks to Nicole Kidman and Moulin
Rouge but she did have it in her
contract that she got to keep all of her
outfits from filming which is amazing
well
Pooh Bear
I do break up
[Music]
what Legally Blonde became a pretty big
hit making over 140 million dollars on
an 18 million dollar budget and I'm no
math whiz but that usually means sequels
in Hollywood which is exactly what we
got in 2003 with Legally Blonde 2 red
white and blonde and a third film that's
currently in the works critics say
though the material is predictable and
formulaic Rhys Witherspoon's funny
nuanced performance makes the movie
better than it would have been otherwise
I think we lost him
it's okay it's dead
nobody move a muscle
[Music]
roaring into theaters on July 18 2001
was Jurassic Park 3 the final film in
the original trilogy this installment
follows a divorced couple played by Taya
Leone and William H Macy Who tricked Dr
Alan Grant with Sam Neal reprising the
role into helping them find their son
who went missing on Ela sorna the same
island from the second Jurassic Park
movie This is the first film in the
franchise to not be directed by Steven
Spielberg although he stayed on as
executive producer and it's also the
first to not be fully based on a Michael
Crichton novel
come back
[Music]
also unlike the previous two films
Jurassic Park 3 features a Spinosaurus
as the main dinosaur antagonist
replacing the good old T-Rex bro they
kill the T-Rex despite all those changes
and mixed reviews from critics the movie
still pulled in nearly 370 million
dollars worldwide an impressive Hall
that was the lowest in the franchise but
good enough to make it into the top 10
that year critics say Jurassic Park 3 is
darker and faster than its predecessors
but that doesn't quite compensate for
the franchise's continuous creative
decline
thank you
[Music]
Lee why didn't you tell me this man
rolls like this I told you I really
didn't I did what you said I did this
mean man speak English to me that means
I go this way and you go this way I go
that way you go this way yes
okay
[Music]
another sequel to hit theaters in the
summer of 2001 as the calendar turned to
August was Rush Hour 2 with director
Brett Ratner returning from 1998's Rush
Hour along with stars Jackie Chan and
Chris Tucker this sequel follows the duo
to Hong Kong on vacation where they end
up getting pulled into a murder
investigation involving two U.S customs
agents
Rush Hour 2's box office Hall of 347
million dollars is the highest total in
the franchise and made it the second
highest grossing PG-13 film of the year
and not only did the film figuratively
print money at the box office it also
actually printed one trillion dollars in
fake money to be used as props in the
film unfortunately some extras pocketed
some of it and tried to spend it which
did not go well critics say Rush Hour 2
doesn't feel as fresh or funny as the
first and the stunts lacks some of the
intricacies normally seen in chance
films
[Music]
man listen I became a cop to stop people
yeah yeah
it's not a review board and I ain't
cocaine
no man
Jesus Christ yeah right
if I was a dealer you'd be dead by now
[__] down on the street and the
chief brings your wife a crisply folded
flag the [__] is wrong with you
patrolling into theaters in October of
2001 was the police drama Training Day
directed by Antoine Fuqua and written by
David Ayer the film follows a day in the
life of a veteran LAPD officer played by
Denzel Washington as he trains Ethan
Hawke's rookie cop character on his
first day in the volatile narcotics unit
in an effort to look as authentic as
possible filming took place in some of
the most infamous neighborhoods of Los
Angeles marking the first time La street
gangs allowed filming while Denzel
Washington Ethan Hawke and the other
cast members met with undercover police
officers local drug dealers and gang
members to prepare for their roles
I'm the man up in this piece
you'll never see the lighter dude
it I'm the police I run [__] you just
live here
yeah that's right you better walk away
go and walk away cause I'm gonna burn
this [__] down
King Kong ain't got on me
Washington earned an Academy Award for
best actor for his performance in the
film while Hawk was nominated for best
supporting actor plus training day one
two MTV movie awards for best villain
for Denzel and best Cameo for Snoop Dogg
critics say the ending may be less than
satisfying but Denzel Washington reminds
us why he's such a great actor in this
taught and brutal police drama you might
be strong but you're not Bulletproof
premiering on TV in October of 2001 was
the action adventure series Smallville
which began on the WB and went along for
the ride when the network merged with
UPN to form the CW the show was a fresh
take on the Superman story that's
centered on a younger Clark Kent dealing
with his emerging superpowers budding
romances and early rivalries it wasn't
until a drama series chronicling a young
Bruce Wayne was pitched and ultimately
denied that the idea for his Superman
origin story started getting kicked
around
foreign
[Music]
it turned out to be the right choice
running for 10 successful seasons and
earning accolades ranging from Emmys to
Teen Choice Awards and perhaps most
importantly it got the blessing of
former Superman film star Christopher
Reeve who even made a couple guest
appearances on the show critics say
smallville's modern retelling of the
Superman Saga benefits from a focus on
Teen Angst and small town drama instead
of comic book camp
foreign
[Applause]
scaring its way into theaters in
November was the Pixar film Monsters Inc
featuring the voices of John Goodman
Billy Crystal Steve Buscemi and Jennifer
Tilly among others set in a world of
monsters powered by the screams of
children the story centers on two
employees at a large scare Factory whose
lives are turned upside down when a
little human girl thought to be toxic to
monsters finds her way into their City
Michael if you don't tell me what's
going on right now we are through you
hear me through here's the truth you
know the kids that they're looking for
Sully lettering we tried to send it back
but water news had the secret plot and
now Randall's right behind us and he's
trying to kill us you'll expect me to
believe that pack of Lies Mike Wazowski
I love you shmoopsy poo the film marked
the directorial debut for Pete Doctor
Who would go on to direct other Pixar
films like up inside out and Seoul and
another Pixar regular Randy Newman
returned to compose the score for
Monsters Inc after doing the company's
three previous films as well he ended up
taking home an Academy Award for best
original song for If I Didn't Have you
but the film Lost out on best animated
feature to the aforementioned Shrek
critics say clever funny and delightful
to look at Monsters Inc delivers another
resounding example of how Pixar elevated
the bar for modern all ages animation
[Music]
um
looks like he's going to be set
[Music]
it's got the glitch bringing some wizard
Rita theaters in November was Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone based on
JK Rowling's hugely popular 1997 novel
of the same name and marking the first
installment of the Harry Potter film
franchise it stars Daniel Radcliffe as
Harry Potter and follows his first year
at Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry as he discovers that he is a
famous Wizard and begins his formal
Wizarding education Radcliffe was joined
by others including Rupert Grant and
Emma Watson along with the late Alan
Rickman as Snape the latter of whom was
hand-picked by JK Rowling and given
secrets about the story that nobody else
would know until the final novel where
Mr Potter would you look at if I asked
you to find me a bezel
I don't know sir and what is the
difference between monks Hood and Wolf
being
Petty
clearly
Fame isn't everything like the book it
was based on the Sorcerer's Stone was a
massive hit earning nearly a billion
dollars during its initial run good
enough to be the highest grossing film
of the year and second highest grossing
film ever at the time it also racked up
three Academy Award nominations and was
followed by seven sequels critics say
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
adapts its source material Faithfully
while condensing the novels over stuffed
narrative into an involving and often
downright exciting big screen magical
caper
yeah
you still don't know if we can use her
yet
actually I haven't even caught her name
Tess
her name is Tess
foreign
ERS in December of 2001 was the heist
Thriller Ocean's 11 directed by Stephen
Soderberg this is a remake of the 1960
Rat Pack film of the same name and stars
George Clooney as Danny ocean who
recruits a crew of 10 to help him Rob
three casinos at the same time joining
Clooney was a rather high profile
ensemble cast meaning that everyone
worked for less than their regular
salaries to help bring down the budget
and once the cast was in place they went
to the Bellagio in Las Vegas which gave
the production access to their security
system to acquire real surveillance
footage of the casino
fourth task construction we need to
build an exact working replica of the
Bellagio Vault to practice something
like that
fifth task intelligence we need those
codes Linus from the only guy who has
all three
Benedict learn to love his shadow
wait wait all I get to do is watch the
guys gotta walk before you can crawl
percent the movie pulled in a worldwide
total of 450 million and was the fifth
highest grossing film of 2001 but the
whole Ocean's crew somehow lost out on
the MTV movie award for best on-screen
team which went to Vin Diesel and Paul
Walker for the Fast and the Furious
critics say as fast-paced witty and
entertaining as it is star-studded and
coolly stylish Ocean's 11 offers a
well-seasoned serving of popcorn
entertainment
back to the shadow
shall not pass
and finally delivering a little jewelry
in the month of December was The Lord of
the Rings The Fellowship of the Ring
based on J.R.R tolkien's 1954 novel The
Fellowship of the Ring the film follows
a young Hobbit named Frodo played by
Elijah Wood who sets out on a mission
with a band of unlikely allies to
destroy a powerful ring in an effort to
save the future of their civilization
this is the first installment in The
Lord of the Rings film Trilogy and was
followed by the two towers and the
Return of the King over the following
two years
oh
[Music]
the film grossed 880 million dollars
worldwide in its initial release
becoming the second highest grossing
film of the year and the fifth highest
grossing film ever at the time it was
nominated for 13 Academy Awards
including best picture and one four for
best cinematography best makeup best
original score and best visual effects
but really it forever instilled the word
Hobbit into the pop culture vernacular
and that's just fine by me critics say
full of eye-popping special effects and
featuring a Pitch Perfect cast The Lord
of the Rings The Fellowship of the Ring
brings J.R.R tolkien's classic to Vivid
life well gosh we did it 2001 from top
to bottom man Harry Potter and the Lord
of the Rings kicking off in the same
year that's big time nerd stuff right
there what's your favorite movie or show
from 2001 thanks for checking out our
year in review for 2001 we'll see you
next time